In the last video, I spoke
somewhat theoretically about
what a null space is
and we showed that
it is a valid subspace.
But in this video let's actually
calculate the null
space for a matrix.
In this case, we'll calculate
the null space of matrix A.
So null space is literally
just the set of all the
vectors that, when I multiply A
times any of those vectors,
so let me say that the vector
x1, x2, x3, x4 is a member of
our null space.
So when I multiply this matrix
times this vector I should get
the 0 vector.
I should get the vector.
And just to make a few
points here, this
has exactly 4 columns.
This is a 3 by 4 matrix, so I've
only legitimately defined
multiplication of this times a
four-component vector or a
member of Rn.
Let me call this X.
And this is our vector X.
This is a member of R4.
It has four components.
And then when you multiply
these, we need
to produce a 0 vector.
The null space is the set of
all the vectors, and when I
multiply it times A, I
produce the 0 vector.
And what am I going to get?
I'm going to have one row times
this and that's going to
be the first entry, then this
row times, that's the second
entry, and then the third row.
So I should have three 0's So my
0 vector is going to be the
0 vector in R3.
So how do we figure out the set
of all of these x's that
satisfy this?
Let me just write our
formal notation.
The null space of A is the set
of all vectors that are a
member of -- we generally say
Rn, but this is a 3 by 4
matrix, so these are all the
vectors that are going to be
members of R4, because I'm using
this particular A, such
that my matrix A times any
of these vectors is
equal to the 0 vector.
In this case it's going
to be 0 vector in R3.
So how do we do this?
Well, this is just a straight
up linear equation.
We can write it that way.
If we were to actually perform
the matrix multiplication, we
get 1 times x1.
Let me write it here.
Let me do it in a
different color.
1 times x1, plus 1 times x2,
plus 1 times x3, plus 1 times
x4 is equal to this 0 there.
So that times that is
equal to that 0.
And then this times this should
be equal to that 0.
So 1 times x1, so you get x1,
plus 2 times x2, plus 3 times
x3, plus 4 times x4 is going
to be equal to that 0.
And then finally we have that
times this vector should be
equal to that 0.
So the dot product of this row
vector with this column vector
should be equal to that 0.
So you get 4x1.
4x1 plus 3x2 plus 2x1 plus 2x3
plus x4 is equal to 0.
4x1 plus 3x2 plus 2x3 plus
x4 is equal to 0.
You just have to find the
solution set to this and we'll
essentially have figured
out our null space.
Now, we've figured out the
solution set to systems of
equations like this.
We have three equations
with four unknowns.
We can do that.
We can represent this by an
augmented matrix and then put
that in reduced row
echelon form.
Let's do that.
I can represent this problem
as the augmented matrix.
1, 1, 4.
1, 2, 3.
1, 3, 2.
and then 1, 4, 1.
And then I augment that
with the 0 vector.
And the immediate thing you
should notice is we took the
pain of multiplying this times
this to equal that, and we
wrote this as a system of
equations, but now we want to
solve the system of equations,
we're going back to the
augmented matrix world.
What does this augmented
matrix look like?
Well, this is just our
matrix A right there.
That's just matrix A right
there, that's just the 0
vector right there.
And to solve this, and we've
done this before, we're just
going to put this augmented
matrix into row echelon form.
What you're going to find is
when you put it into row
echelon form, this right side's
not going to change at
all, because no matter what you
multiply or subtract by,
you're just doing it all times
0, so you just keep
ending up with 0.
So as we put this into reduced
row echelon form, were
actually just putting matrix A
into reduced echelon form.
So let me do that, instead
of just talking about it.
So let me start off by keeping
row 1 the same.
Row 1 is 1, 1, 1, 1, 0.
And then I want to eliminate
this 1 right here, so let me
replace row 2 with row
2 minus row 1.
So 1 minus 1 is 0.
2 minus 1 is 1.
3 minus 1 is 2.
4 minus 1 is 3.
0 minus 0 is 0.
You can see the 0's aren't
going to change.
And then let me replace this
guy with 4 times this guy,
minus this guy.
So I can only get rid of this.
So 4 times 1 minus 4 is 0.
4 times 1 minus 3 is 1.
4 times 1 minus 2 is 2.
4 times 1 minus 1 is 3.
4 times 0 minus 0 is 0.
Now I want to get rid of, if I
want to put this in reduced
row echelon form, I want
to get rid of that
term and that term.
So let me keep my middle
row the same.
My middle row is 0, 1, 2, 3.
So that's 0 on the augmented
side of it, although these 0's
are never going to change, it's
really just a little bit
of an exercise just to
keep writing them.
And my first row, let me replace
it with the first row
minus the second row, so I
can get rid of this 1.
So 1 minus 0 is 1.
1 minus 1 is 0.
1 minus 2 is minus 1.
1 minus 3 is minus 2.
And 0 minus 0 is 0.
And let me replace this last
row with the last row minus
the middle row.
So 0 minus 0 is 0.
1 minus 1 is 0.
2 minus 2 is 0.
I think you see where
this is going.
3 minus 3 is 0.
And obviously 0 minus 0 is 0.
So this system of equations
has been reduced, just by
doing reduce row echelon
form, this problem.
If I just rewrite this right
here, this can be written as a
system equations of x1 minus
x3 minus x4, right?
The 0 x2's is equal to 0.
And then this second row right
here, there's no x1, you just
have an x2, plus 2x3, plus 3x2
is equal to 0, and this
obviously gives me no
information whatsoever.
And so I can solve this.
I can solve this for x1 and
x2, and what do I get?
I get x1 is equal
to x3 plus x4.
Actually, I made
a mistake here.
This is x1 minus x3 minus 2
times x4 is equal to 0.
So if I rewrite this, I get x1
is equal to x3 plus 2x4.
And then I get x2.
Let me do that in green.
x2 is equal to minus
2 x3 minus 3x2.
So if I wanted to write the
solution set to this equation,
if I wanted to write it in terms
of this, I could write
x1, x2, x3, x4 is equal to
-- what's x1 equal to?
It's equal to x3 times
1 plus x4 times 2.
Right?
I just got this right here from
this equation right here.
x1 is equal to 1 times
x3, plus 2 times x4.
That's just that, right there.
Now, x2 is equal to x3
times minus 2, plus
x4 times minus 3.
What am I doing?
I'm losing track of things.
This x2 right here is x2 plus
2x3 plus 3x4 is equal to 0.
So x2 is equal to minus
2x3, minus 3x4.
Right.
Like that.
Sorry, my brain isn't completely
in the problem, I'm
making these silly mistakes.
But I think you understand
this now.
So then what is x3 equal to?
Well, it's just equal
to 1 times x3,
plus 0 times x4, right?
x3 is equal to x3.
And what's x4 equal to?
It's equal to 0 times
x3 plus 1 times x4.
So all of the vectors in R4,
these are a member R4, which
satisfy the equation, our
original equation, ax is equal
to 0, can be represented as a
linear combination of these
two vectors, of those
two vectors, right?
These are just random scalars
that are a member of-- We can
pick any real number for x3
and we could pick any real
number for x4.
So our solution set is just a
linear combination of those
two vectors.
What's another way of
saying a linear
combination of two vectors?
Let me write this.
The null space of A, which is
just a solution set of this
equation, it's just all the
x's that satisfy this
equation, it equals all of the
linear combinations of this
vector and that vector.
What do we call all the linear
combinations of two vectors?
It's the span of those
two vectors.
So it equals the span of that
vector and that vector.
Of the vector 1, minus 2,
1, 0, and the vector
2, minus 3, 0, 1.
And this is our null space.
Before letting you go, let me
just point out one interesting
thing right here.
We represented our system of
equation like this and we put
it into reduced row echelon
form, so this is
A and this is 0.
This right here is, let me make
sure I have some space,
let me put it right here.
That right there is the reduced
row echelon form of A.
And so where essentially this
equation, this is a linear
equation that is trying
to solve this problem.
The reduced row echelon form
of A times our vector x is
equal to 0.
So, all the solutions to this
are also the solutions to our
original problem, to our
original ax is equal to 0.
So what's the solution
to this?
All the x's that satisfy this,
these are the null space of
the reduced row echelon
form of A.
Right?
So here are all of the x's, this
is the null space, this
problem, if we find all of the
x's here, this is the null
space of the reduced row echelon
form of our matrix A.
But we're saying that this
problem is the same problem as
this one, right?
So we can write that the null
space of A is equal to the
null space of the reduced
row echelon form of A.
And that might seem a little
bit confusing, hey, why are
you even writing this out, but
it's the actually very useful
when you're trying to calculate
null spaces.
So we didn't even have
to write a big
augmented matrix here.
We can say, take our matrix A,
put it in reduced row echelon
form and then figure out
it's null space.
We would have gone straight
to this point right here.
This is the reduced row echelon
form of A, and then I
could have immediately solved
these equations, right?
I would have just taken the dot
product of the reduced row
echelon form or, not the dot
product, the matrix vector
product of the reduced row
echelon form of A with this
vector, and I would've gotten
these equations, and then
these equations would
immediately, I can just
rewrite them in this
form, and I would
have gotten our result.
But anyway, hopefully you found
that reasonably useful.